hi everyone i'm pleased to announce
the release of my new book beyond order
12 more rules for life
i've been thinking for quite a while
about what i would do to announce this
book and
what popped into my mind constantly was
that i should start the announcement
with a thank you
to all my viewers
listeners and readers
for the tremendous support that you've
shown to my work in
all of its forms and for the multitude
of
kind and thoughtful
and often erudite and moving
letters that you've sent to me and to my
family and
comments that you've left on youtube and
and other forms of social media i've
been constantly
amazed and i mean constantly
and i mean amazed by the volume of
correspondence that has come my way and
by
the continual support i've received from
so many people
and so um i'm pleased to have
been of use i'm pleased that people
found my last book
12 rules for life helpful and engaging
and i hope
very much that the same thing will prove
true of this
new book i'm going to
read the 12 rules from this book
and then i'm going to read some excerpts
from it so that you can get a sense of
the book
these 12 rules like the 12 rules in the
previous book
were drawn from a longer list of 42
that i published on quora rule 1
do not carelessly denigrate social
institutions
or creative achievement
rule two imagine who you could be
and then aim single-mindedly at that
rule three do not hide
unwanted things in the fog
rule four notice that opportunity lurks
where responsibility has been abdicated
rule five do not do what you hate
rule six abandon ideology
rule seven work as hard as you possibly
can
on at least one thing and see what
happens
rule eight perhaps my favorite
try to make one room in your home as
beautiful as possible
rule 9 if old memories still upset you
write them down carefully and completely
rule 10 plan and work diligently
to maintain the romance in your
relationship
rule 11 do not allow yourself to become
resentful deceitful
or arrogant and rule 12
be grateful in spite of your suffering
each of these rules
is accompanied by an illustration as in
the case of my previous book
this time the illustrator is yulia fogra
and she's done i think a lovely job we
held a competition for the
illustrations and she her work was
at least in my opinion the best of the
bunch
and she's produced these lovely artworks
that have a classical fairy tale
appeal and so i think they add a
bit of beauty to the book so i'm going
to read a couple of sections now
the first reading is from rule three
and to remind you rule three is
do not hide unwanted things in the fog
and this is
from a subsection entitled what
is the fog imagine that you are afraid
you have reason to be you're afraid of
yourself
you're afraid of other people you're
afraid of the world you're nostalgic for
the innocence of the past
for the time before you learned the
terrible things
that shattered the trust characterizing
your childhood
the knowledge you have gained of
yourself other people in the world has
embittered more than enlightened
you've been betrayed hurt and
disappointed
you've become distrustful even of hope
itself
as your hope has been repeatedly
shattered and that is the very
definition of
hopelessness the last thing you want to
know
is more better to leave what is
enshrouded in mystery better as well to
avoid thinking
too much or at all about what could be
when ignorance is bliss after all tis
folly to be wise
imagine more precisely that you are so
afraid
that you will not allow yourself even to
know
what you want knowing would
simultaneously mean hoping
and your hopes have been dashed you have
your reasons for maintaining your
ignorance
you're afraid perhaps that there is
nothing worth wanting
you're afraid that if you specify what
you want precisely
you will simultaneously discover and and
all too clearly
what constitutes failure you are afraid
that failure is the most likely outcome
and finally you're afraid that if you
define failure
and then fail you will know beyond a
shadow of a doubt that it was you that
failed
and that it was your fault so
you do not allow yourself to know what
you want
you manage this by refusing to think it
through
you are happy satisfied and engaged
sometimes and
unhappy frustrated and nihilistic other
times but you will not inquire deeply
into why
because then you would know and then you
would encounter yet again
shattered hope and confirmed
disappointment
you were also afraid but for different
reasons to allow others
to know what you want first if they were
to find out just what you wanted
then they might tell you and then you
would know
even if you were fighting against
gathering that very knowledge
second if they knew they could then deny
you what you truly wanted
even needed and hurt you much more
efficiently than they might
if your deepest desires and therefore
your vulnerabilities
remain secret the fog that hides
is the refusal to notice to attend to
emotions and motivational states as they
arise and the refusal to communicate
them both to yourself
and to the people who are close to you a
bad mood
signifies something a state of anxiety
or sadness
signifies something and not likely
something that will please you to
discover
the most probable outcome of
successfully articulating an emotion
that has accrued without expression over
time
is tears and admission of vulnerability
and pain which are also feelings that
people do not like to allow particularly
when they are feeling
distrustful and angry who wants to dig
down into the depths of pain and grief
and guilt
until the tears emerge
and voluntary refusal to take notice of
our emotional states
is not the only impediment to dealing
with them
if your wife or husband or whomever else
you are tangled up with
unhappily at the moment says something
that comes too
close to the painful truth for example
then a sharp and insulting remark will
often shut them up
and is therefore very likely to be
offered
this is partly a test does the person
being insulted
care enough about you and your suffering
to dig past a few obstacles and unearth
the bitter truth
it is also partly and more obviously
defensive
if you can chase someone away from
something you yourself
do not want to discover that makes your
life easier
in the present sadly it is also very
disappointing if that defense succeeds
and is typically accompanied by a sense
of abandonment
loneliness and self-betrayal
you must nonetheless still live among
other people and they with you
and you have desires wants needs and
however unstated and unclear
and you are still motivated to pursue
them not least because it is impossible
to live
without desire want and need
your strategy under such conditions
show your disappointment when someone
close to you makes you unhappy
allow yourself the luxury and pleasure
of resentment when something
does not go your way ensure that the
person who has transgressed against you
is frozen out by your disapproval
force them to discover with as much
difficulty as possible exactly what they
have done to disappoint you
and finally let them grope around
blindly in the fog
that you have generated around yourself
until they stumble
into and injure themselves on the sharp
hidden edges
of your unrevealed preferences and
dreams
and maybe these responses are tests too
tests deeply associated with the lack of
courage to trust
if you really loved me you would brave
the terrible landscape that i have
arrayed around myself
to discover the real me
and perhaps there is even something to
such claims implicit though they may be
a certain testing of commitment might
have its utility
everything does not have to be given
away for free
but even a little unnecessary mystery
goes a long way
and you must still live with yourself in
the short term
perhaps you are protected from the
revelation of your insufficiency
by your refusal to make yourself clear
every ideal is a judge after all
the judge who says you are not
manifesting your true
potential no ideals
no judge but the price paid for that
is purposelessness this is a high price
no purpose then no positive emotion
as most of what drives us forward with
hope intact
is the experience of approaching
something we deeply need and want
and worse when we are without purpose
chronic overwhelming anxiety as
focused purpose constrains what is
otherwise likely to be the intolerable
chaos of
unexploited possibility and too much
choice
if you make what you want clear and
commit yourself to its pursuit
you may fail but if you do not make what
you want clear
then you will certainly fail you cannot
hit a target
that you refuse to see
you cannot hit a target if you do not
take aim
and equally dangerously in both cases
you will not accrue the advantage of
aiming but missing you will not benefit
from the learning that inevitably takes
place when things do not go
your way success at a given endeavor
often means
trying falling short recalibrating
with the new knowledge generated
painfully by the failure
and then trying again and falling short
often repeated ad nauseam
sometimes all that learning impossible
without the failure
leads you to see that aiming your
ambition in a different direction would
be better
not because it is easier not because you
have given
up not because you are avoiding but
because you have learned
through the vicissitudes of your
experience that what you seek is
not to be found where you were looking
or is simply not attainable in the
manner
by which you chose to pursue it
so what might you do what should you do
as an alternative to hiding things in
the fog
admit to your feelings
this is a very tricky matter and it does
not simply mean
give in to them first
noting much less communicating feelings
of
petty anger or pain due to lonesomeness
or anxiety about something that might be
trivial or
jealousy that is likely unwarranted is
embarrassing
the admission of such feelings is a
revelation of ignorance
insufficiency and vulnerability
second it is unsettling to allow for the
possibility
that your feelings however overwhelming
and convincing
might be misplaced and in your ignorance
pointing you in the wrong direction
it is possible that you have
misinterpreted the situation entirely
for reasons of which you remain
fundamentally unconscious
it is for such reasons that trust is
vital
but trust of the mature and tragic sort
a naive person trusts because he or she
believes that people are essentially
or even universally trustworthy
but any person who has truly lived has
been
or has betrayed
someone with experience knows that
people are capable of deception
and willing to deceive that knowledge
brings with it
an arguably justified pessimism about
human nature
personal and otherwise but it also opens
the door to another kind of faith in
humanity
one based on courage rather than naivete
i will trust you i will extend
my hand to you despite the risk of
betrayal
because it is possible through trust to
bring out the best in you
and perhaps in me so i will accept
substantial risk to open the door to
cooperation and negotiation
and even if you do betray me in a not
too
unforgivable manner assuming a certain
degree
shall we say of genuine apology and
contrition on your part
i will continue to extend my hand and
part of the way i will do that
is by telling you what i am feeling
a certain necessary humility must
accompany
such raw revelations
i should not say at least not ideally
you have been ignoring me lately i
should say instead
i feel isolated and lonely and hurt and
cannot help but feel that
you have not been as attentive to me
over the last few months as i would have
liked
or that might have been best for us as a
couple but i'm unsure if i am just
imagining all this
because i'm upset or if i'm genuinely
seeing
what's going on
the latter statement gets the point
across but avoids the accusatory stance
that so often serves as a first defense
against a serious
get to the bottom of things conversation
and it's very possible that you are
wrong about just what it is that is
causing you to feel the way you do
if you are you need to know it because
there's no point in propagating errors
that are causing you and others pain
and interfering with your future best
to find out what is true best to
disperse the fog
and find out if the sharp objects you
feared were lurking there
are real or fantastical
and there is always the danger that some
of them are real
but it is better to see them than to
keep them
occluded by the fog because you can at
least
sometimes avoid the danger that you are
willing to see
this is an excerpt from rule eight try
to make one room in your home
as beautiful as possible it's from a
subsection entitled
memory and vision
the pride of the peacock is the glory of
god
the lust of the goat is the bounty of
god the wrath of the lion
is the wisdom of god the nakedness of
woman
is the work of god excess of sorrow
laughs excessive joy weeps
the roaring of lions the howling of
wolves the raging of the stormy sea
and the destructive sword are portions
of eternity
too great for the eye of man
william blake from proverbs of hell the
marriage of heaven and hell
when i was a child i knew the contours
and details of all the houses
in my immediate neighborhood i knew the
back alleys
the places behind the fences the
location of
each crack in the pavement and the
shortcuts that could be taken
from one place to another my
geographical locale
was not large but i had explored it
thoroughly and my knowledge of it was
very detailed
now that i am an adult the same is not
true
i lived in fairview the town i grew up
in for most of my childhood and
adolescence
for only nine years but i'm still able
to picture in high resolution
the street i lived on i have lived in
toronto
on the same street for more than twice
that long
but i still have only a vague sense of
the houses that surround me
i do not think that is a good thing i
feel
far less at home because of it
it is as if when i walk down the street
and glance at a local house
i think house as an icon
because really what practical difference
does it make to me
what particularities characterize each
house
and then my attention is turned to
something else i did not
see the house with its specific shingles
colors
flowers and architectural details
despite the interest that might have
been elicited in me
had i paid careful attention
by this point in my life i have seen so
many houses
in so many places that i know what a
house is likely to do
when i walk by which is very little
thus i ignore the engaging
idiosyncrasies
and beauties of its details its unique
character for better or worse and see
just enough to stay oriented as i walk
past
and continue to think and be elsewhere
as i do so there is real
loss in that i am simply not there
in my adult neighborhood the same way i
was as a child
in my hometown i i'm separated
from the reality of the world
and a very deep sense of belonging is
missing
in some important way because of that
perception has been replaced for me with
functional pragmatic memory
this has made me more efficient in some
ways but the cost
is an impoverished experience of the
richness of the world
i remember when i started working as a
junior professor in boston
when my kids were about two and three
years old
i was very preoccupied with my work
trying to
keep up trying to advance my career
trying to make enough money
to support my family on a single income
i would come home and take a walk with
tammy and our children
michaela and julian i found it very
difficult to remain
patient with them i had too much work to
do
always or believed i did and had
disciplined myself through years of
effort to focus continually
on that if we went for a walk
i wanted to know exactly where we were
going
just how long it would take to get there
and precisely when we were going to get
back
this is no attitude to adopt when trying
to have a pleasant
and reasonable time with toddlers not if
you want to immerse yourself in the
experience
not if you want to watch and participate
in the pleasure
they take in their timeless discovery
not unless you want to risk missing
something of crucial import
it was very difficult for me to relax
and focus on the present and watch my
little kids
pursue their meandering route through
the neighborhood with
no particular destination purpose
or schedule in mind engaging themselves
deeply in an encounter with a local dog
bug or earthworm or in some game they
invented
on the way now and then however i could
snap
briefly into that same frame of
reference
that is one of the wonderful gifts
provided by young children
and see the pristine world they
inhabited still
untrammeled by practiced and effective
memory
capable of producing pure joy in the
newness
of everything but i was still possessed
enough by my future concerns to be
involuntarily
pulled back into intense preoccupation
with getting the next thing done
i knew perfectly well i was missing out
on beauty and meaning
and engagement regardless of whatever
advantages and efficiency my
impatience bought i was narrow
sharp and focused and did not waste time
but the price i paid for that was the
blindness demanded by
efficiency accomplishment and order
i was no longer seeing the world i was
only seeing the little i needed to
navigate it
with maximum speed and lowest cost
none of that was surprising i had the
responsibilities of an adult
i had a demanding job i had to take care
of my family
and that meant sacrificing the present
and attending
to the future but having little children
around and noticing their intense
preoccupation with the present
and their fascination with what was
directly around them
made me very conscious of the loss
that accompanied maturity
great poets are expressly aware of this
and they do what they can
to remind the rest of us
there was a time when meadow grove and
stream
the earth and every common sight
to me did seem appareled in celestial
light
the glory and the freshness of a dream
it is not now as it hath been of your
turn wheresoever i may by night or day
the things which i have seen i now can
see no more
ye blessed creatures i have heard the
call
ye to each other make i see the heavens
laugh with you in your jubilee my heart
is at your festival
my head half it's coronal
the fullness of your bliss i feel
i feel it all
oh evil day if i were sullen
while earth herself is adorning this
sweet
may morning and the children are culling
on every side
in a thousand valleys far and wide fresh
flowers while the sun shines warm
and the babe leaps up on his mother's
arm
i hear i hear with joy i hear
but there's a tree of many one a single
field which i have looked upon
both of them speak of something
that is gone the pansy at my feet
doth the same tale repeat
wither has fled the visionary gleam
where is it now the glory
and the dream
william wordsworth owed
intimations of immortality from
recollections of early childhood
some in fact never lose the glorious
vision of childhood
this is particularly true of artists
and indeed seems a vital part of what
makes them artists
william blake the english painter
printmaker and poet
appears to have been one such person
he inhabited a uniquely visionary world
blake perceived something closer to what
the philosopher emmanuel kant
termed the thing in itself
then do most mortals left as we are with
the pale
reflection of our surroundings that are
increasingly restricted
mature perceptions deliver to us
blake was also exquisitely sensitive to
the metaphoric or dramatic significance
of each apparently isolated event
the manner in which each event is rife
with endless
poetically echoing connotations
every farmer understands every tear from
every eye becomes a babe in eternity
this is caught by females bright and
returned to its own delight
the bleak the bark ballow and
roar are waves that beat on heaven's
shore
the babe that weeps the rod beneath
writes
revenge in realms of death
the beggar's rags fluttering in air
does to rags the heavens tear
the soldier armed with sword and gun
palsied
strikes the summer's sun the poor man's
farthing is worth more than all the gold
on afric's shore one
might run from the laborer's hands
shall buy and sell the miser's lands
or if protected from on high does
that whole nation sell and buy
he who mocks the infant's faith shall be
mocked
in age and death
he who shall teach the child to doubt
the rotting grave
shall never get out he who respects the
infant's faith
triumphs over hell
and death william blake
argues of innocence lines 67-90
the vision of a true artist such as
blake
is truly too much because what is beyond
our memory restricted perceptions
is too much it is the unfathomable
totality of the world
past present and future bound up
together
every level connected to every other
level nothing existing in isolation
everything implying something vital but
beyond our comprehension
and all of it speaking of the
overwhelming mystery of being
the visionary concentrates on something
we all see
hypothetically a vas of flowers perhaps
and
all its complexity and beauty each bloom
springing
forth out of nothingness before its
dissolution and return
a haystack in the spring and its
appearance in the summer
autumn and winter observing and
portraying the absolute mystery of its
existence
with its different shades of light and
color as well as the underlying
commonality of form
which we can easily confuse with the
full and incomprehensible
actuality of what is there
how do you know but every bird that cuts
the airy way
is an immense world of delight closed
by your senses five
william blake from a memorable fancy
the marriage of heaven and hell
to perceive then goes painting irises
from which the illustration that begins
this chapter is derived is for example
to gaze through a window
back into the eternity that our
perceptions once revealed
so that we can remember how awe
inspiring and miraculous
the world really is under the mundane
familiarity to which we have reduced it
to share in the artist's perception
reunites us with the source of
inspiration
that can rekindle our delight in the
world
even if the drudgery and repetition of
daily life
has reduced what we see to the narrowest
and most pragmatic of visions
but for those first affections those
shadowy recollections
which be they what they may are yet the
fountain light of
all our day are yet a master light of
all our seeing uphold us cherish
and have power to make our noisy years
see
moments in the being of the eternal
silence
truths that wake to perish never
which neither listlessness nor mad
endeavor
nor man nor boy nor all that is at
enmity with joy can utterly abolish
or destroy william wordsworth
owed intimations of immortality from
recollections
of early childhood
all of this is very frightening it is
frightening to perceive the shells of
ourselves that we have become
it is frightening to glimpse even for a
moment the transcendent reality
that exists beyond we think we border
our great paintings with luxurious
elaborate frames
to glorify them but we do it at least as
much to insist to ourselves that the
glory of the painting itself
ends at the frame that bounding
that bordering leaves the world we are
familiar with
comfortably intact and unchanged
we do not want that beauty reaching out
past the limitations imposed on it
and disturbing everything that is
familiar
we do the same with museums those
asylums for genius
we isolate everything that is great
everything that could in principle be
distributed throughout the world
why cannot every small town have a
shrine
devoted to one great piece of art
instead of having every piece collected
in a manner impossible
for anyone to ever take in at once
is not one masterpiece enough for a room
or even for a building ten great works
of art or a hundred
in a single room is absurd given that
each
as a world in and of itself such mass
collection
is degrading of the unique singular
particularity and worth
of what is priceless and irreplaceable
it is fear that entices us to imprison
art and no wonder
have you reckoned a thousand acres much
have you reckoned
the earth much have you practiced so
long to read have you felt so proud to
get at the meaning of poems
stop this day and night with me and you
shall possess the origin of all poems
you possess the good of the earth and
sun
there are millions of suns left you
shall no longer
take things at second or third hand
nor look through the eyes of the dead
nor
feed on the specters in books
you shall not look through my eyes
either nor take things from me
you shall listen to all sides and filter
them
from yourself walt whitman
song of myself
it can be overwhelming to open ourselves
up to the beauty in the world
that we as adults have painted over with
simplicity
in not doing so however in not taking a
proper walk with a young
child for example
we lose track of the grandeur
and the awe that untrammeled world
it can be overwhelming to open ourselves
up to the beauty in the world that we as
adults
have painted over with simplicity
in not doing so however in not taking a
proper
walk with a young child for example
we lose track of the grandeur and the
awe
the untrammeled world is constantly
capable of producing
and reduce our lives to bleak
necessity
that's from my new book beyond order
12 more rules for life
thanks for your attention
bye bye